so I'm very curious man I have a lot of
questions not do them as quickly as
possible it's never gonna happen okay
I'm very curious how much when you
obviously booked some great people great
cameos if you will to be in the movie
that's the technical term I appreciate
you using it it's a Hollywood movie
making term cameo that honestly the band
cameo stole yeah when they made their
hit song word up and so now anytime you
put a cameo in a movie you are
contractually obligated to put the words
word up somewhere in the movie so that's
why I say it non-stop yeah that's why I
Lauren is constantly saying word up word
up so yeah so just look for it yeah yeah
exactly
um you booked really cool people for the
film I'm very curious how much do they
know exactly what zach is gonna be how
much is that them aware of what's coming
and how much is the reaction genuine
like I can't believe he just asked me
that we never tell the celebrities
anything that's gonna happen so
everything is a genuine reaction
everything is improvised we I'll
certainly check in with the celebrity
beforehand and say hey it might get a
little mean out there and to their
credit most of them are really into it
and want it to be mean so you know if
you watch the movie it's it's us just
trying to get up there and push it as
far as we can push it before they flip
out and punch one of us um one of the
things I recommend everyone watching
this interview to watch the end credits
of this movie and work your way
backwards right exactly yeah it's sort
of like you know pincers betrayal
you know I'm just curious when you're
showing rinse when when you're showing
that in the end credits you're showing a
lot I don't want to reveal but you're
showing some stuff how much do they per
have to approve that stuff or once you
step on set it's like fair game to use
anything once they step on set I usually
say boy you just done did it now because
we can use anything from this
you're gonna hate it we try to make the
movies so that every celebrity in it
will hate it and disavow it and at this
point they've all watched it and liked
it I don't know what I'm doing it's
terrible jumping into what I'm imagining
making this was a blast
yeah what's like a day or two that
you're always gonna remember oh wow I
mean there are a bunch of them I think
that one one day that was really
memorable was we were shooting outside
really late at night in the desert and
we had a rain machine and it was
freezing cold and we were out there for
like 15 hours and it was a real long day
but we were still having so much fun and
I think that's one of the things that I
truly wit well I well you weren't yeah
well Ryan and Giovanni and we got this
warm car yeah uh-huh but that's it was
so fun because it was one of those
things were like you're all kind of
complaining and I'm like uncomfortable
but you're able to still have a good
time and make something really funny and
I always it was like summer camp in the
winter when it was freezing cold yeah so
yeah you you still like find a way to
like band together and enjoy all the
like difficult moments we all really
liked working with each other so it
would be impossible to do a movie like
this if everyone wasn't friends and
there was a lot of trust and we were
just like having fun yeah I was gonna
say there is a way to do it you just pay
someone obscene amounts of money I
didn't even see Nevada money how tough
was it though to get this film off the
ground because one of the things I
really didn't even know it was coming
for a little while and all of a sudden
I'm like wait what we kept it a secret
for a long time it was not that hard to
get off the ground other than just like
figuring out how to do it but once we
pitched it to Netflix and they said okay
and gave us some money to do it the the
real challenge was just figuring out how
to do it it was a massive undertaking
but we just kept it a secret for a long
time and until finally we just put the
trailer up I was gonna say that's what
Netflix is known for like no one knew
what Breaking Bad movie was coming and
all the sudden there's like a trailer in
the movie well I mean and suddenly Bob
Odenkirk just in an interview spoils it
and they're forced to rush the
around the next day what else does Bob
Odenkirk know was finger the speaker
secret who knows he spoiled the Afghan
Whigs he spoiled the breaking bad movie
these rattles around in this is secret
for a long time that was hard for me
because I really want to tell everyone
that I was in this so excited so it's
hard to keep itself a secret and we
wouldn't tell Bob was know until Bob
Odenkirk UH one of the things about
Netflix is I'm curious you must have
deleted scenes in this you must have had
a longer cut is there any chance of
deleted scenes or any alt stuff ending
up on Netflix for fans to actually watch
I the first cut was three hours and that
was even without a bunch of scenes that
we just knew weren't gonna make it in so
I would love to put together like an
Robert Altman desk Nashville kind of
three-hour cut that just goes down
divergent weird paths but the one thing
I will say is for every interview that
we shot we shot an actual interview with
them and so we plan to put those out at
some point oh really yeah um okay now
I'm very curious how long are the
interviews there are five minutes or so
in the movie they're all like Cherie
seconds a minute but we shot like actual
real episodes with everyone oh that is
so ingenious
yeah and that was a really neat part for
me because I got to watch all of those
happen live and I mean as someone who's
been a fan of the series you've watched
them just on tape I'd have gone tape em
I got to see how the other look if
you're a fan of bread great if you're a
sausage great put them together you've
got something in my opinion with a
little mustard a hot dog oh yeah right
on that note congratulations on the
movie and I'm very curious about seeing
though do you know when they're gonna be
released us well yeah I do I think
starting Friday there's the full
interviews yeah one a week living that
is all saying I'm looking forward to it
thank you so much and Congrats on
everything thank you